CREATE  JAREN JACKSON WITH THE
OFFENSIVE REBOUND AND THE
JOSEPH.
>> Greg: MULDER.
AND HOW ABOUT NIGHT.
DO A MICK A BUSINESS DECISION
HERE.
KELLY OLYNYK SAYS I TYLER HERROK
AS HE JUST TAKES HIS THESE IME
SAID, LOOK.
17-10.
THAT WAS NASTY. MAGIC TO
SAVE T THINGS LIKE THIS FROM
HIM.
HE DOESSTACEYYOUNG, THIS
>> Adam: JAZZ. 19 YEARS IN THE
LOT OF CONTROL.
>> Justin: THE AWKWARD SHOT,
CAMPAIGNING TO BE A FAN
FAVORITE?
LOOK AT THIS SHOT. 11 NOW.
5 OF 10 SHOOTING.
HE'S KNOCKED
>> IT'S NO GOOD!
>> WOW.
>> AND
DIDN'T WANT TO CHALLENGE JOKER.
CLUB  THIS YEAR.
BRIDGES.
GIANNIS ON THE PUSH. A QUICK
CROSSOONE.
AND HE
BROWN.
FOR TWO.
>> B
SAYS TAKE THAT WITH YOU, MILES
HIGHLIGHT!
BAD MAN.
THAT WAS
HARRISON BARNES KNOCKS IT DOWN!N